à deux pas du lac du rousset de sa
fameuse forêt la coordination du center
parcs installés ces caravanes et
déployer ses banderoles si le lieu se
veut ouvert à tous l'anonymat de
certains participants est de rigueur
nous devons pas être filmés pour deux
raisons certains sont dans des actions
jugées illégales comme la zad à roybon
et donc du coup peuvent être exposés à
des recherches des poursuites aux visées
de la police ne souhaite pas être
identifiée comme sa liste et la deuxième
raison est d'éviter l'émergence de porte
parole qui du coup ce serait parce qu'il
serait plus visible sur un niveau
hiérarchique différents au sein de nous
alors que nous sommes sur un
fonctionnement horizontalement pour le
moment il n'est pas prévu que la forêt
du rousset devienne une zone à défendre
l'esprit du moment et plus à
l'information
et si la mobilisation se voulait
symbolique par le nombre moins d'une
cinquantaine venir ici avec un sens
c'est important de montrer que les
pouvoirs en place économiques comme
politiques
peut-être doivent consulter s'intéresser
et dialoguer avec avec des citoyens
qu'ils sentent qu'ils sentent concernés
entre représentations théâtrales et
balades
certains ont été à la rencontre des
promeneurs l'occasion une nouvelle fois
d'attaquer les projets de center parcs
est de démontrer les impacts écologiques
cette belle nature pourquoi l'abîmé avec
une bulle à 29 degrés toute l'année
quand on nous dit que la planète est en
souffrance
l'eau que cela va nécessiter qui n'est
absolument pas en quantité suffisante
ici avec des projets complètement
grandiloquent de faire venir de l'eau de
la loire
enfin des choses qui me paraissent
aberrante la caravane qui n'a ni ici ni
ailleurs reprendra la route demain pour
finir son périple le 28 avril à roybon
en isère autre lieu d'implantation
possibles d'un seul tord parc